I have a painting by Phoebe of nine
women then they they all look like women
and my grandmother's prayer meeting
group so whenever I'm obliged to do
something I take that painting and I
look at that painting there's an empty
chair and I think now what would grandma
do what would she say I can almost hear
her voice say my sister you know what's
right just do right you don't really
have to ask anybody truth is Right may
not be expedient it may not be
profitable but it will satisfy your soul
it brings you the kind of protection
that bodyguards can't give you try to be
all you can be to be the best human
being you can be tried to be that in
your church and your temple try to be
that in your classroom do it because it
is right to do people wouldn't know you
and they will add their prayers to your
life they'll wish you well if your name
is mentioned and people say oh hell oh
damn and then you're doing something
wrong but if your name is mentioning
people say oh she's so sweet
he's so nice oh god bless her so try to
live your life in a way that you will
not regret years of useless virtue and
inertia and timidity pick up the
the battle take it up it's yours this is
your life this is your world I'll be
leaving it long before you under the
ordinary set of circumstances you make
your own choices
you can decide life isn't worth living
and it would be the worst thing you can
do how do you know so far try it see so
pick it up pick up the battle then and
make it a better world just where you
are yes and it can be better and it must
be better but it is up to us courage is
the most important important of all the
virtues because without courage you
can't practice any other virtue
consistently you can't be consistently
kind or fair or humane or generous not
without courage because if you don't
have it sooner or later you'll stop and
say if the threat is too much the
difficulty is too too high they the
challenge is is too great you just
watched two amazing clips to Maya
Angelou take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]